how long everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast crisper cast 9 genome
engineering experimental design and
applications presented by Daniel Daniel
full card product manager a horizon
discovery
I am Marjorie Taurus of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by horizon discovery
for more information about our sponsor
please visit www.thegrape.com
like on the green Q&A button located in
the lower left of the presentation
window and type your questions into the
box that appears on the screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Daniel for card I will now turn the
presentation over to her
thank you very much Marjorie so I'm one
of the plant managers at Verizon
discovery and and the talk today is
going to be covering more information on
how we use our wealth of experience in
genome engineering techniques to build
cellular models that can be utilized and
applied in basic research in drug
discovery and development target
validation etc so today I'm going to
introduce you to some key considerations
that you need to understand and take
note of when designing your experiment
as well as outlining some interesting
applications with a few case studies so
I'll begin with a short background on
what we do at Horizon and followed by an
introduction into one of the most
powerful gene engineering platforms that
we use and for our cell engineering and
screening assays CRISPR cows nine will
go through the key considerations to
take when designing your gene
engineering projects and these are the
points and and drivers that will help
you find your genotype of interest
faster and help accelerate your research
lastly I'll go through a few examples of
how CRISPR cows 9 and can be applied to
different areas of research from report
to cell lines and just screening for
those genotypic drivers causing your
particular phenotype of interest so
horizon was built upon gene editing
technologies and this remains at the
core of everything that we do we believe
that gene editing underpins the route to
personalized medicine which is a key
word in in so many different
applications nowadays so what we do is
we edit genes in so lines to build human
disease models so we the cell builders
and these models are used to gain
knowledge of those genetic drivers and
disease and and also to provide
knowledge of drug targets and as well as
well as patient response to those key
chemotherapeutic agents so horizon aim
is to put the right genetics in the
right model in the right context to
provide rich insight into human disease
so as researchers working in the area of
the human genome there is now
unparalleled access to genetic
information that has been obtained from
healthy individuals diseas'd individuals
and sequence at an exome level a whole
genome level and horizon discovery we
create isogenic cell lines
with the gene editing technologies that
we'll discuss today and we use these
cell lines to evaluate therapeutics and
to identify targets that may be of
interest to validate those targets and
and also for Diagnostics to produce
reference standards that allows control
for variability in those assays to
determine which patients should receive
which drugs and this has been made
possible by and large by the revolution
of genome engineering and particularly
the discovery of the use of care spec
has 9 so the Chris book has nine
revolution all began in January 2013
which was marked by a major breakthrough
in in genome engineering with four labs
simultaneously engineering CRISPR
Katherine system to induce precise
cleavage at mammalian genomic loci and
this resulted in an explosion of
research and conducted across many model
systems disciplines and fields and from
oncology research immunotherapy looking
at embryo Genesis and going into in vivo
and looking at how this could be used in
a person and further on around around
data handling which is just incredible
the the capacity that Chris Burke has
could could contribute in this area and
it really is making impossible
experiments possible and so until this
point broadly speaking we have three
options open to us to explore gene
function which are the use of patient
derived cell lines with pre-existing
disease associated mutations to study
gene function and while the patient
samples are of incredible use they are
variable from each patient patient the
mutations will be different from
patients patient and just the source it
is not renewable once you've used it
you've used it and in terms of gene
modulation and RNA based RNA I based
loss of function
these were common to look at the effect
of removing aging from the system and on
the converse using over expression and
to look into gain-of-function
experiments so what is CRISPR cows 9
Chris Beck has 9 is a genome editing
tool that's able to cut double-stranded
DNA in a very targeted fashion so Chris
Beck has nine genome editing is achieved
when you transfer to cell with the cows
9 protein and that along with a
specifically designed guide RNA so in
the example here we've used a guide RNA
there is 20 base pairs long and it's
specific to your target of interest so
not every 20 base pair DNA sequence is
suitable as a guide RNA as the sequence
must have an adjacent pan motif and the
pan motif is a three base pair sequence
which consists of an n GG sequence and
that n can be any nucleotide but it must
be adjacent to your sequence of interest
and there are a number of different
considerations to make when you select
that guide RNA and each of which I will
go into more detail later on in the talk
so when you've transfected yourself the
guide RNA that you've designed directs
the catheline protein to the DNA target
site and it hybridizes with its matching
genomic sequence so the cast iron
protein is now in the right place and
it's able to cut the double-stranded DNA
and when the cell repairs that break
errors can occur resulting in the gene
knockout or the knock in where
additional genetic modifications can be
introduced so for the flip on the next
slide the gene here has four exons and
it has a start codon in exon 2 so we've
designed our guide RNA to bind with an
exon 3 of the gene so the cows 9 is
directed by the guide to that target
location in x13 it cuts the DNA and
causes a double strand break and then
the system relies on the DNA damage
repair pathway which is then activated
and we use the self intrinsic DNA repair
machinery to generate the genotypes and
subsequently in the pipes that we desire
so to generate knockout cells we will
allow the double strand breaks to be
repaired by the repair system with
non-homologous end joining and this is
an error-prone repair mechanism there
often results in small insertions and
deletions which can cause a frameshift
in the protein coding sequence resulting
in a premature stop sequence in order to
generate a knock in we Coe transfect
cells with the donor that contains the
desired mutation and this donor template
is incorporated into the genome by a
more precise DNA repair mechanism called
homology directed repair and the
difference here is that you have a donor
and you design that donor with flanking
homologous sequences that can direct
where that particular mutation should be
integrated into that double strand break
induced by the cosine
I've gone through the basics of Christic
house 9 and how it works I'm going to
run through these seven key
considerations that you should address
before performing your experiment
firstly this is crucial to your
experiment and you need to choose the
right cell line to use you want to use a
cell line that best models your disease
and that is rigorous rigorously
characterized and the importance here is
because there are so many opportunities
for variability in getting that
targeting efficiency you're looking for
so the questions to ask yourself first
are can my cell line be transfected
different cell lines will have different
transmission efficiencies and will
require different conditions and so at
Horizon we test a number of conditions
including LipPerfection and different
concentrations of those reagents and
also different nuclear flexion
techniques and based on the experience
that we've gained over the last 10 years
we have over a 90% of console' lines now
with a transaction efficiency of at
least 50% which gives us an enhanced
fool to progress into the next stages
the ones who have transfected ourselves
the next thing to ask is how we enrich
that population and so we use fact
sorting with GFP to identify those cells
that have been transfected so once we
have that pool we need to undergo a
limiting dilution and a limiting
dilution is quite a strenuous process on
the cells but we need to do this in
order to achieve those clonal
populations so we know which ones now
have the transfection and have the the
double strand breaks and so we then go
through a limiting dilution step where
we test different media conditions and
that might be a standard media a
conditioned media with some extra things
in there and and we will analyze the
recovery of those cells and in the
example here you can see that the
standard media actually resulted in
better recovery and then the final part
is to
ask yourself whether the cell cultures
homogeneous if you need to evaluate
whether the morphology of those cells is
as expected
and once you've characterized your cell
line you've answered those key questions
to make sure that you have the best
transmission efficiency and the
targeting efficiency you're looking for
the next stage is to think about your
gene targets is your modification going
to affect the gene and is it going to
affect the growth of the cell line will
the modification be lethal to the cell
is this a really fundamental gene to the
survival and therefore how are you going
to approach that and will there be a
decrease in viability in the mutant
cells versus those parental cells that
you started with that results in your
parental cells outgrowing your mutant
and can you overcome this by tweaking
your protocols and timings to perform a
limiting dilutions a little earlier in
the music for example so that you keep
them at the same state and will there be
a change in the phenotype after the
modification do you have a Keith in the
fact that you're looking for and can you
assess this in the mutant line and the
parental and look for those differences
a key really key consideration with gene
engineering is making sure you
understand the copy number of your gene
in the cell line that you're using so we
can in in-house we validate this using
droplet digital PCR and and what this
allows you to do is ensure that you have
the number of cells and the number of
copies per cell confirmed prior to
performing the engineering and so in a
normal human cell line we expect to have
two copies of the gene in the cell
however when you use cell lines that
have been in culture for years and years
or a cancerous nature there can be some
gene duplications and multiple copies of
the chromosomes so the karyotype here is
for the HeLa cell line very commonly
used cell line has been a culture for a
very long time and you can see that it
has multiple copies of many of the
chromosomes so you need to know what the
copy number is before hand and
evaluating it through chocolate did your
PCI we'll give you a quantitative answer
for that so you know the copy number of
your gene now and the next stage is the
transcripts
does your gene have multiple transcripts
and which ones you targeting do you want
to target all of them do you want to
target only a selection of them and
there's software like ensembl you can
compare and perform analysis to ensure
that you are targeting the region that
you want to and and also the pseudogenes
a common and it can be common and so if
you are aware of the pseudo gene you can
look at the bioinformatics tools
available to you to work out where those
regions of high homology are and and
determine if you want to design your
guide outside of that so that you only
target your gene and not the pseudo gene
and lastly does my target gene have
difficult to amplify regions are there
poly T regions that I should be avoiding
and will they have a high GC content or
will they'll be repeat palindromic
regions that you need to consider when
designing those guides and there you
have that information the next stage is
to actually start designing those guide
RNA them and choosing the ones that are
most relevant to you and your experiment
what makes a good guide you want to
avoid repeat stretches again you can use
software such as been chilling that we
and we've used here that will help you
evaluate the options for guide RNAs
based on their on target and then off
target score so what you want with a an
ideal guide RNA is to have a very high
on target and a low off target
combination and that will give you the
high specificity are looking for if you
identify a number of guides that have
similar results you might want to dig
deeper into those off targets and and
have a look at where they fall there you
don't want them to fall into a coding
region which could result in you your
guide targeting another gene that you're
not looking to investigate and so if you
have all of the off targets which are in
non-coding regions you would want to
select that over the one that had coding
off target
so for a knockout project when designing
the guides horizon discovery we would
target the first four exons and this
reduces the chances of you inducing the
frameshift and still having a truncated
protein existing and alternatively if
you have a gene that you know encodes a
protein that has a very crucial
functional domain you could target the
functional domain introduced frameshift
here and know that you're creating a
functional knockout for a knockin you
want to design your guides as close as
possible to the site for the insertion
of the doughnut template and once you've
taken all of these considerations into
into account you should always carry out
validation of the guides so this will
increase your targeting efficiency and
will increase the number of clones that
you ultimately get out at the end so we
generate five guides all that have
similar on and off target schools and we
transfect those into a workhorse cell
line and our choice here is the head two
nine three we harvest the cells 48 hours
to 72 hours post transaction and realize
the cells extract the DNA and PCR
amplify those regions of interest the
assay that we carry out to assess the
validity and of the guide RNA and how
much how well they cut is a p7
endonuclease assay and what this does is
it recognizes and Cleaves in perfectly
match DNA so with that non-homologous
end joining and with the addition of
extra donors it identifies those
mismatches and it cuts the sequences
which results in smaller bands being
visible on on this gel so if you in this
example you can see that there are three
columns all of which have a have
cleavage sites so guide one three and
four the first column there is is a
control guide and so bind not performing
validation
in this situation you if you used guide
the guides that did not have cleavage
events you would have a very low
targeting efficiency you wouldn't be
finding the points that you were looking
for so this really emphasizes the need
to assess the cutting efficiency and the
targeting for your guides so the donor
design is specific for more for the
knock ins and for a knockout
you don't need to have a donor but it's
at this stage where you should start
designing your screening strategy so how
you're going to identify those small
insertions and deletions that would
result in those gene knockouts so for a
knock in your path lines and cut site
must be as close as possible to that
knocking location and in our repair the
donor template that we want to use we
need to determine the screening strategy
for this and it might be targeting and
sequencing a specific snip that we're
introducing or if it's a tag you can
amplify a region where that targeted
allele has the tag incorporated and we
would recommend introducing silent
mutations into that pam site which
guides that RNA which will prevent the
cows 9 also cutting that donor template
and and there are there are different
types of donors that can be used so a
plasmid might be more commonly used for
the introduction of a reporter tags and
while the single-stranded all ago donors
would be used for introducing snips so
in the donor design here you want to
determine your genotype and as fast as
possible so for a knockout and you the
t7 essay might be used you want a robust
process to identify your genotype and so
this example here with a t7 endonuclease
a safe screen and with an example you
know with a lethal screen we knew that
the knockout would potentially be lethal
to the cells
and so we didn't expect to see too many
targeted events and on the the figure
here you can see the stars indicate
where we have found a target event
occurring and so if you are expecting to
see a knock out efficiency of much
higher you may want to skip the steppin
and go into perform a sequencing
analysis immediately so tied and crisp
ID are two software packages that can
help with the analysis of your results
following your your targeting and so
tied analyzes the sequence upstream of
your mutation and identifies two
different traces for the two copies of
the gene you can see that there's a few
that say four copies this emphasizes a
non clonal population and is likely to
selves being in that well ideally we
want two out of frame mutations so here
you can see you've got in the orange it
highlights ones where there's an outer
frame mutation and also an in-frame
mutation so we need it to be out of
frame to cause the frame shift and
result in stop codon so those in green
you can see have two out of frame
mutations and so those are the ones that
you would like to take forward the
addition of crisp ID it's it's lower
throughput compared to the tired of
asset ID you could see that there was a
number of different clones here that we
had all of the information on where is
with crisp IDs it's lower throughput but
it does add you an additional layer so
it gives you not only the that there is
a mutation because you the sequence the
exact sequence from that particular
clone so that's usually valuable and so
for a knock in screen and you need to
add that screening strategy into your do
that donor design like the incorporation
of a silo mutation into the Pam site so
you can just screen for those positives
and there's a couple of examples here so
a has 30 positive clones and this is a
knockin screen and B has 162 positive
clones now the only difference here with
with this screen in particular is that
this is exactly the same cell line and
but it's a different gene and therefore
it's a different guide RNA and so this
shows how your guide is key in affecting
the targeting efficiency and how that
may vary depending on the target that
you are trying to set you're trying to
change and modify for a positive screen
here you can design a primer for your
targeted snip in allele that you've
turned that if you've edited and so this
example of 116 positive clones and 54
positive clones are using the same guide
but it's in a different cell line and so
again this emphasizes that the cell line
itself can vary in the targeted
efficiency it may have been due to the
transaction and and why those key
considerations earlier in the process is
really important and the final
consideration we're going to go through
is the validation of those cell lines so
firstly you want to confirm your clone
allottee and the way in which we do that
in-house is that we use a cell matrix
scanner and this scans the bottom of the
plate to identify when we have one cell
in each well and you can see it's a zero
you've got a single cell and that has
expanded through day 10 and this is an
example of a clonal population
alternatively you could use a single
cell sorting via so cytometry and then
perform PCR on each cell and so once
you've confirmed the clone ality you
want to confirm that the genotype with a
suite of PCR and therefore knock out
identification you might want to perform
a PCR that is over the guy over the exon
3 mutation there and in addition you
want to perform a much longer PCR which
will allow you to see if there's been
any larger deletions that you might not
be able to see from that shorter PCR in
your gene of interest so for a knockin
project and we perform a few more PCRs
ones you know targeted allele also
looking at the non targeted allele which
will help confirm the [ __ ]
number of your gene and another way to
do this would be topo cloning to
individually sequence the alleles you
want to clarify that there has not been
any off target incorporation and the way
you might do this is you've performed
that in silico analysis with the
software to identify the off target
score so if you dig a little deeper into
those you could work out what the top
ten hits that were predicted were and
then validate those to ensure that there
is no and there's been no off target
effects and cutting with the cat line
and the guide the karyotype is also
confirmed to ensure that has not been
affected by the gene engineering and the
cell lines are confirmed to be
contaminant free and not just from a
bacterial contamination but also from a
wild-type cells so this comes back to
the clone allathee of the population you
don't want to have a parental so that's
also mixed in there with your mutant and
because it will affect the copy number
and your allelic frequency of that
variant and then lastly you want to be
able to confirm the identity of that
suspected phenotypic change if you know
there's going to be a reduction in cell
viability or you know there's going to
be a resistance to a drug now you want
to confirm that that is the case in the
mutant compared to the parental cell
line and again that emphasizes the
reason at horizon why we generate
isogenic cell lines they're exactly the
same except for that key mutation that
you are trying to introduce so now we've
gone through the tools and the
considerations for how you design your
CRISPR cows nine gene engineering
projects I'm going to spend the rest of
the talk and describing how you can
apply this technology to your research
with a few different examples so
reporter and fluorescently labeled cell
lines can be very useful in research
they can tell you whether a
transcription factor is on or off if you
have a cell service marker that's
expressed you can evaluate the
localization of a protein and and also
look at that in respect to whether its
input
a particular organelle that is expressed
and a horizon we've developed a protocol
that allows for rapid and robust
endogenous tagging of your joint gene of
interest so indigenously tagged genes
are favored versus exogenous plasmid
base over expression modules which can
be problematic and it's much clearer the
absence of the non tagged proteins
reduces the complexity when you come to
quantify that protein number and we have
this technique is explained in more
detail in the podcast at the link in the
in the bottom of the slide here and this
technique uses CRISPR but it also uses
that non homology and joining repair
mechanism that's used in a knockout and
and so it doesn't require the need for a
donor with homology region design it is
a one-size-fits-all donor and so we've
used taro JSP and the guide RNA is
designed to target the CAD line to your
particular gene of interest and we've
developed a suite of target organelles
and where we've tagged genes
specifically known to be expressed in a
particular cell compartment and there's
a few examples over here so for the
endoplasmic reticulum we have targeted
cow AR and also PDI a4 we have a couple
of nucleic markers that we've tagged
they're specific to the nucleus and also
one for mitochondria and centrosome
localization and this might allow you to
perform a pulldown assay or live cell
imaging of those proteins without having
to fix yourself and extract and etc so
next application I'm going to go through
and are about genetic screens I'm going
to start with forward genetic screens
here and this is an approach to identify
genes or a set of genes that are
responsible for a particular phenotype
so you use mutagen eyes self and to
identify your phenotype and then you
identify the mutations subsequent to
that that have resulted in that
phenotype
so this is important in positive
selection so you have cells have been
transduced with the cows nine protein
and a library of guide RNAs so the cell
population then undergoes selection
which might be treatment with a drug or
cell surface marker to positively select
them and so all the cells that then
remain will have the phenotype that
you're looking for so with a drug
treatment for example it would be the
resistance to the drug and so those
remaining viable cells would be selected
the examples here are of essential genes
that are in cancer immunotherapy
effector function and what this this
group did was to transfer an Omer cells
with around 125,000 guide RNAs which
were specific to 20,000 genes and these
cells were then treated with t-cells to
enthuse t-cell fighter toxicity which is
expected and so those cells that would
survive the treatment with the T cells
were then collected and sequence to
identify the genes that conferred the
resistance of this cytotoxicity and this
group used three different techniques
with the same candidates that are
identified and they pulled out one in
particular the APL NR which the key
candidate identified and confirmed to be
important in the distance its g-protein
coupled receptor and it's involved in
interfering gamma secretion fired the
jak-stat pathway and it was within this
pathway that the al P R M was believed
to work through so this emphasizes the
usefulness of these genetic screens and
where you know what the phenotype is
that you're looking for but you want to
know how you were getting there and what
genes are responsible for that and so
reverse genetic screens are the same but
slightly different so the reverse
genetic screens are where you're
investigating the phenotype of an
organism
following the disruption of a known gene
so you know the gene this time and you
want to work out what phenotype that
confers so the opposite approach to the
forward genetic screen and so with these
genetic screens you can perform
transcriptional analysis
and at horizon we have created thousands
of hats on and knock out cell lines so
we know what the genes are and we wanted
to evaluate the phenotypes by looking at
the expression difference in that RNA
seek profile so we have treated the
cells with a number of different stimuli
you extract the RNA and then performed
RNA seek on those cells so different
stimuli produce stimulate specific
expression signatures and those stimuli
that were similar resulted in more
closely related expression signatures so
we went on to use 64 of our knock out
cell lines and that were all important
in tyrosine kinase signaling with ten
different stimuli so we know the genetic
mutations and then we then profiled
those through RNA seek and we were able
to recapitulate known genetic
dependencies so of the signature of the
sponsors we were able to identify the
response in to the interferon gamma so
in a and B the figures here you can see
that interferon gamma there was there
was no response and there was no jak1
response which is exactly what we
expected given that the cell line we
were studying was the jack one knockout
line and the same principle was found
with the FDF r1 where fgf won the ligand
for this saw no downstream and
activation and so this technology in the
suite of thousands of different hat one
knockout cell lines that we have
available it's hugely valuable when
you're trying to evaluate the gene
responsibility and the function so now
I'm going to switch gear just a little
and I'm going to give you an
introduction into CRISPR a and CRISPR I
so CRISPR a is CRISPR mediated
transcriptional activation and CRISPR I
is CRISPR mediated transcriptional
repression
so the hypothesis for these adapted
Crysta techniques was to use dead cast 9
I mean by that is that it's
catalytically inactive it's deactivated
and so no longer has that endonuclease
activity that we've seen in the previous
slides where it can cut that
double-stranded DNA so it still uses a
guide RNA but instead it uses the guide
to take it to that target location but
the dead cast line is targeted there to
say a promoter region that it can
activate to inhibit the transcriptional
transcriptional activity of the promoter
so the CRISPR I you use the dead cast
line with or without a transcriptional
inhibitor and KRA B domain to complex
with the guide RNA and to target
promoter regions to cause
transcriptional repression or knockdown
of the gene and alternatively the dead
cows 9 can fuse to transcriptional
activators and targeted to the promoters
to increase the expression in terms of
the requirements for the guide RNA
designs for Christopher I it needs to be
in close proximity to that genes
promoter region to result in the gene
being silenced versus with a crystal a
the guide RNA what we want is to design
it in close proximity to the genes
transcriptional start site to result in
gene activation and so this next couple
of slides are going to look at applying
a genome wide CRISPR screen and to
identify long non-coding RNA low side
that were regulating a gene neighborhood
causing resistance to chemotherapy
agents and long non-coding RNAs have
critical roles in diverse cellular
processes and a notoriously difficult to
study in an endogenous setting as they
are hard to transcriptionally regulate
and therefore is a really good
application for CRISPR iron CRISPR a it
is a similar set up to a full genetic
screen in that you induce the cells with
a CRISPR a library which is designed to
around 10,000 transcriptional start
sites for the long non-coding
ranae's the selection isn't applied
which is those chemotherapeutic agents
and those that have resistance were
selected and their transcriptional
profile was investigated and in see--he
there were a number of different
candidates along current non-coding rnas
that were mediating the resistance and
in this figure they identified mov 3b as
a key candidate I was able to confirm
its role in the clinic as well and so
this demonstrates a huge amount of power
to these CRISPR a screens by really
getting the most outdoor data and
identifying new key targets that you
haven't even considered previously and
little knows in a particular pathway of
interest to you and this is just some
additional data showing how there was a
difference between the controls and the
treated and also how that what that
expression profile looks like with
respect to sensitivity and resistance to
the chemotherapeutic agent so if you
want something more about CRISPR a
increase for eye screens how you may do
them in tandem and what sort of data
that you can achieve from these we
recently hosted a webinar with dr.
Benedict cross from Horizon who's our
CRISPR a and eye expert he provides more
detail on how we've used these
Christopher adapter techniques and house
and they link he will enable you to
access this recording so to wrap up I'd
like to thank you all for listening to
the talk today and leave you with some
final messages about how at horizon we
are the gene editing experts and we're
conscious constantly pushing the
boundaries of Christopher genome
engineering in our screening
applications and in development of
cellular models for basic research into
drug development and mechanistic in done
under standing and with that I would
like to welcome any questions that you
have thank you very much thank you Dan
or Colcord for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower lap of the presentation
window type your questions into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for let's
get started
our first question is is CRISPR going to
take over from modulation techniques
such as si RNA or is there a place for
both technique and yeah that's a really
good question
where CRISPR and si RNA have their own
advantages and disadvantages
where CRISPR can provide you with a
clear approach of knocking out your gene
completely allows you to really
understand the mechanisms that it's
involved in there's no residual gene
expression at all and you can compare it
to the parental well the si RNA is a
more delicate modulating approach rather
than editing it directly so I think
there is place for both techniques and
even in combination where you use CRISPR
plus the modulator to assess and more
more deeply interrogate those pathway
interactions for example in synthetic
lethality where and you may need an
additional level of understanding thank
you for that answer our next question is
what is the knob down or a knock up
level with CRISPR information
architecture I think so with CRISPR I
and a and the change in gene expression
that we see of these tools is partially
influenced by the locus that you are
that you're interested in and it's its
area again it's thinking about all of
those different things that we spoke
around the talk about the the gc-rich
nor all of those considerations the
targeting efficiency of the cells and
and also the baseline expression level
but overall we would expect to see
around 10 fold changes in the gene
expression at most life sign I would
like to once again thank Daniel for card
for her presentation I would also like
to thank horizon discoveries for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
2017 you'll receive an email from
Lavery's letting me know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement through
the colleagues who have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye